president Trump new chief of staff
needed less than a day to show his
authority retired General John Kelly
told White House communication director
Anthony scaramouche II to get out the
move indicates the former Homeland
Security Secretary has the president's
go-ahead to take command of a chaotic
White House staff a photo shows Anthony
scare Moochie in the Oval Office
yesterday morning just hours before he
was asked to leave major Garrett is at
the White House with the sudden shake-up
major good morning good morning ten days
on the job that makes Anthony scare
Moochie the shortest tenured
communications director in the history
of the White House and with two
resignations and one firing in his wake
he's also the most disruptive we just
swore in general Kelley he will do a
spectacular job I have no doubt the
first big decision from the new chief of
staff John Kelly thank you kissing
hot-headed communications director
Anthony scaramouche II goodbye just days
after his dramatic arrival mr. skur
Moochie felt it was best to give chief
of staff John Kelly a clean slate the
White House said in a terse statement
his expletive laced tirade with The New
Yorker last Wednesday demeaned a chief
of staff Reince Priebus and chief
strategist Steve Bannon scare Moochie
tried to make amends with senior adviser
and mr. Trump's son-in-law Jared Kushner
a confidant called scaramouche's new
yorker rant an incredible act of
self-immolation he could never recover
from the president certainly felt that
Anthony's comments were inappropriate
for a person in that position and he
didn't want to burden general Kelley
also with that line of succession
scaramouche II the third communications
director in six months was escorted out
of the White House Monday afternoon
leaving many of the president's aides in
shock previous resigned days after
scaramouche's arrival former press
secretary Sean Spicer resigned over
scaramouche's hiring but if you're gonna
keep leaking I'm gonna fire everybody
Ciara Moochie arrived threatening to
root out disloyal leakers and boasted of
his tight relationship with the
president I want to congratulate you and
have
done a fantastic job general and we look
forward to if it's possible an even
better job as chief of staff as for
those who remain the president has given
general Kelly full authority in the West
Wing
all staff including Kushner and wife
Ivanka are said now to report to Kelly
on Instagram Ivanka Trump posted this
picture of Kelly swearing in something
journalists were not allowed to cover
saying she look forward to working
alongside the general names mentioned as
possible scare Moochie successors
include special assistant to the
president hope Hicks counselor to the
president Kellyanne Conway and David
Lipan a communications professional
kelly worked with at the Pentagon and at
Homeland Security let major thanks